في هذه الأراضي الهادئة التي لا تبعد كثيرًا عن
حدود لبنان المضطربة مع إسرائيل،
يبدو الأمر وكأن الحرب تزحف. ومع اقتراب
اليوم الذي تخلى فيه الكثيرون عن
موسم قطف الزيتون الذي ينتظرونه كل
عام، هناك أولئك الذين ما زالوا
يقطفون الزيتون مقابل بضعة دولارات
يوميًا لإطعامهم.  تبدو
عائلاتهم عبر الحدود الجنوبية
مع إسرائيل أكثر فأكثر،
تبدو القرى مهجورة في بلدة ميرون على بعد
أميال قليلة من الحدود، والشوارع
هادئة، والعديد من المتاجر مغلقة الآن،
وغادر حوالي نصف سكانها أمتعتهم
وغادروا، وقد سمعوا القتال الدائر هناك.
لم تصل مدينتهم بعد، لكن الناس
هنا رأوا كل ذلك من قبل، ذكريات
آخر حرب كبيرة مع إسرائيل في عام 2006، لا
يزال الناظر الخام يعيشها خلال تلك
الحرب الأهلية في لبنان، والاحتلال الإسرائيلي الذي دام عقودًا طويلة
لجنوب لبنان والانهيار
الاقتصادي للبلاد،
هذا المخبز الصغير هو  كل ما كان عليها هي
وعائلتها
البقاء على قيد الحياة
خلال الأسبوعين الماضيين هو
تبادل يومي لإطلاق النار المميت بين
الهجوم الإيراني الذي تدعمه جماعة حزب الله اللبنانية شبه العسكرية في إسرائيل والهجوم المضاد الذي
يقتصر في الغالب على منطقة ثلاثة أمتار على
جانبي الحدود ولكن  إن التهديد
بحرب شاملة محسوبة أو عكسية
أمر حقيقي للغاية، فقد أدى بالفعل إلى طرد
ما يقرب من 20.000 شخص من منازلهم
وفقًا للأمم المتحدة في مدينة
تاي الجنوبية. لقد عاد مركز الكوارث إلى
العمل، وكان عليهم التعامل مع أكثر
من  6,000 شخص فروا هنا يقول المسؤولون المحليون إنه مع
امتداد القتال إلى خارج
المنطقة الحمراء، فإن كل هذه القرى التي أصبحت الآن مهجورة
على طول الحدود يفر المزيد والمزيد منها،
ونخشى أن
يزداد العدد، ونأمل
ألا يحدث ذلك ولكن لدينا  للتخطيط
لأسوأ شيء
العدو الإسرائيلي أه لا نستطيع النوم علينا أن نكون
دائما أه ننام
بعيون مفتوحة كما قالوا مدارس مثل هذه
أغلقت وتحولت إلى
ملاجئ مؤقتة مع الدولة بالكاد
تعمل ولبنان  تعيش الأغلبية الآن
في فقر، وليس لديهم ما
يكفي من الموارد للتعامل مع
أزمة جديدة. كثيرون هنا لا يريدون التحدث
إلينا أمام الكاميرا، إنها الإهانة التي جلبها
النزوح، بالكاد تمكنت أمل من الخروج
بالملابس التي ترتديها على ظهرها فقط.
أرسل لها أحد الجيران صورة للأضرار التي
لحقت بمنزلها في إسرائيل ولبنان يقولان إنهما
لا يريدان حربًا أخرى ولكن مع توترات
عالية إلى هذا الحد والعدوان قريبان جدًا،
يستعد الجميع للأسوأ.